[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue et
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver avec
nos deux invités qui sont ce soir
gabriel cluzel bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste rédactrice en chef du site
boulevard voltaire vous êtes également
essayiste votre dernier ouvrage enraciné
nous sommes tous d héritier a été
publiée aux éditions arte geie puis nous
retrouvons aussi grand plaisir comme
toujours j smadja bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes le directeur
de cabinet du maire de nanterre et vous
avez été le conseiller spécial de marie
george buffet la ministre communiste la
jeunesse et des sports
c'était au siècle dernier mais on s'en
souvient on recommence si vous le voulez
bien par une actualité internationale
c'est un véritable triomphe qui a
enregistré la droite madrilène hier il y
avait en effet une élection dans la
région de madrid
et c'est le parti populaire qui détenait
déjà le pouvoir dans la région de madrid
mais qui a doublé son score grand succès
donc du pp mais aussi de son allié
d'extrême droite le parti vox écoutez
cette réaction enthousiaste comme on
pouvait l'imaginer d'isabelle diaz ayuso
c'est la présidente de la communauté de
madrid
c'est de protéger l'enseignement public
privé spécialisé vous ayez un autre
système de santé de veiller à toutes les
grandes choses voilà l'une des
conséquences de ce scrutin c'est
le départ de la vie politique de pablo
iglesias le leader du parti de gauche
radicale podemos qui avait abandonné ses
fonctions gouvernementales pour faire
campagne dans cette région son score a
eu son parti par don a eu un score tout
à fait convenable puisque ils ont
emporté 10 sièges contre 7 dans la
précédente à la précédente élection mais
il a considéré néanmoins qu' il avait
échoué à faire barrage au parti
populaire
comment est ce que vous expliquez cluzel
se ce succès qui surprend par son
ampleur
alors si on en croit les observateurs
moi je n'étais pas en espagne mais pour
écouter un peu ce que disaient les uns
et les autres
ces deux facteurs le premier c'est sans
doute les outrances du côté de podemos
et en cela peut-être que jean luc
mélenchon s'en faire de comparaisons
absolue parce que tous les pays sont
différents mais devrait on peut-être en
prennent de la prendre de la graine et
l'observer de près parce que
un certain nombre d'outrance de de
propos excessifs de pendant cette
campagne ont probablement choqué les
espagnols l'autre le pendant de tout
cela c'est que isabelle diaz a mené une
campagne elle de droite décomplexée tout
à fait clair sur une ligne bien bien
établies alors il y avait quand même un
pari mais qui en espagne a bien
fonctionné dans cette région de madrid
c'est qu'elle a toutes tous tabler sur
la liberté en cette période de co vide
est là elle elle n'était pas du tout
partisan d d d enfer mist comment les on
en parle aujourd'hui c'est vrai que dans
un pays où il ya moins de protection
sociale que le nôtre il était important
que les restaurateurs et les
entrepreneurs puissent continuer à
travailler elle a joué cette carte là et
cette carte là a été tout à fait tout à
fait gagnante et donc elle s'est
présentée comme une droite qui s'assume
et là aussi et bien on a envie de dire
peut-être faudrait-il que la france en
prennent de la graine et août la droite
française en prennent de la graine pour
pour survivre alors vous effectivement
ella ella ella vox également dans les
comment dire dans l'aide à ses côtés qui
la soutient mais qui n'est pas un peu en
position de force au temps qui est ce
parti l'aurait espéré
sans doute parce que précisément ils
avaient le gaz s'est montré extrêmement
fortes dans ses positions donc elle a un
petit peu stoppé la progression de ce
parti que d'aucuns peuvent là aussi pour
faire une comparaison qui vaut ce
qu'elle vaut peuvent rapprocher parfois
du rassemblement national
donc tout ça est intéressant il faut
quand même savoir que vous me dites si
je me trompe mais je crois qu'elle a
remporté autant de sièges
enfin le son parti remportait autant de
sièges que l'ensemble de la gauche regli
donc c'est malgré tout un fort revers
pour absolument 64 sièges
donc c'est le double de son score de
2019 64 sièges à comparer aux 13 sièges
du parti vox dont vous parliez
à l'instant gilles smadja c'est
intéressant l'un des ressorts de ce
succès apparemment
et probablement aussi de la forte
mobilisation des madrilènes puisqu'il ya
eu un taux de participation élevé
c'est la position d' isabelle diaz
pendant le confinement en disant moi je
refuse que les gens arrêtent de vivre il
faut que les bars les restaurants
restent ouverts on n'a pas eu ça du tout
en france c'est une surprise d'ailleurs
le taux de participation à cette
élection est une grande surprise puisque
il ya eu 75 % de votants et on s'y
attendait pas du tout voilà donc c'est
peut-être qu'il faut d'ailleurs du coup
se s'interroger sur la grande vague
d'abstention comme nous annonce pour les
élections régionales où le 20 juin en
france peut-être que finalement ça ne
sera pas ça et donc ça devrait nous
faire réfléchir
mais en tout état de cause oui c'est
cette participation est surprenante et
c'est vrai que la campagne du parti de
droite du parti populaire qui quand même
revenait de loin il faut dire que le
parti populaire il était tombé très bas
en espagne au cours des dernières années
là ils remontent qui revient à son
niveau au niveau qui était le sien
voilà avant l'arrivée des socialistes au
pouvoir elle a fait campagne le leader
de la droite elle a fait campagne
exclusivement sur le thème de en gros il
ne faut pas de restriction il ne faut
pas de restrictions sanitaires il ne
faut pas obliger les gens à porter un
masque il ne faut pas empêcher les gens
d'aller travailler il ne faut pas fermer
les restaurants il faut laisser toutes
ouvertes
bon c'est on peut quand même
s'interroger sur le caractère
responsable de cette campagne parce que
quand même ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'en espagne a pas eu de mort
c'est un des pays qui a été le plus
touché par l'épidémie
c'est un des pays où on a vu des scènes
catastrophique y à il ya quelques mois
de ça où on voyait les corbillards se
suivre et pourtant les électeurs will
lead alors oui pop parce qu'on sait très
bien que la majorité de la population
n'est pas touché par
par le cos vide et du coup on joue les
uns contre les autres
alors on joue la liberté des uns
effectivement au détriment de la de la
santé et du risque pour les autres bon
voilà c'est un choix qui a été fait je
suis pas sûr que la politique y gagne
franchement je ne suis pas sûr que les
idées y gagne mais c'est un choix qui a
été fait pour gagner les élections
après l'autre enseignement de cette
élection c'est effectivement que une
fois de plus bas la gauche au pouvoir
elle échoue elle et ça c'est un
enseignement qu'il faut tirer ça veut
dire que la gauche même ce qu'on a
appelé la gauche radicale même ce qu'on
a appelé l'alliance entre le parti
socialiste et pour demos on voit que
finalement eh bien ça ne marche pas
c'est à dire que les les électeurs
finalement les habitants de toute cette
grande région de madrid qui est d'une
région de plusieurs millions de
personnes et biens ont exprimé aussi ils
n'ont pas voté que par rapport à
l'épidémie ils ont aussi voté sur le
fait qu'ils ont qu'ils sont relativement
déçu par par la politique qui est menée
depuis revu depuis trois ans par
l'alliance entre le parti socialiste et
peau des mollahs au pouvoir donc ça
aussi c'est un élément majeur de cette
d'enseignements de cette élection
oui on rappelle que le parti populaire
était au pouvoir jusqu'en 2018 où il a
été renversé par une motion de censure
de façon tout à fait dévorer l'arctique
par par le leader du ps pedro sanchez
qui donc qu'il gouvernait avec son allié
podemos déranger ce qui était d'ailleurs
le l'adversaire visait en priorité par
isabelle diaz dans cette campagne
quelques réactions de nos internautes
d'abord saint père virant ce qui n'est
pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous cher
à gabrielle qui dit les outrances les
plus choquantes viennent de diaz die
ouzou et de vox kriss kross considère au
contraire que la droite ait l'air doit
se trompent pisé comme isabelle diaz et
puis cette question qu'on vous pose sur
twitter les pays européens ont-ils envie
de droite pour gouverner et vous
répondez oui à 79% qu'est ce qui fait
que nous avons eu envie d'élargir un peu
le débat au-delà de l'espagne et bien
c'est entre autres ce sondage récent du
cevipof qui est le centre d'étude de la
vie politique de sciences po
et des enquêtes ont été faites alors en
l'occurrence port en espagne mais le
résultat de madrid montre que
apparemment c'est la même situation
des sondages ont été faits dans 4 pays
en france en allemagne au royaume uni en
italie on a demandé aux gens où vous
vous positionnez vous sur l'échiquier
politique alors on n'a pas mis tout le
monde parce que il ya une minorité que
qui se positionne à l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche il ya à peu près 20%
dès gens qui disent moi je ne me
positionne nulle pa mais si on garde
juste ces trois grandes familles que
sont la gauche le centre et la droite on
s'aperçoit que la droite est très
largement dominante à 33% et qu' elle
progresse elle progresse en france
elle progresse en allemagne 33 % à
droite contre 22% qui se dit à gauche et
20% qui se dit au centre
c'est étonnant gabriel puisque moment où
la droite française est en capilotade le
la droite dans la société est assez
présente semble-t-il dans beaucoup de
pays en europe
oui il ya une différence entre la droite
en tant qu'institution politique si
j'ose dire d'un et puis la droite telle
qu'elle est perçue par l'électorat non
ce qui est intéressant en effet c'est
que pourquoi on a ces résultats là parce
que par exemple balle à la thématique de
l'immigration des migrants l'identité
est au coeur de la préoccupation d'un
des européens c'est évident il n'y a pas
que cela est ce intéressant là aussi de
revenir à l'europe elle a fait une
campagne sur le mérite
sur l'entrepreneuriat les la lakers
isabelle diaz walla pardon le pour
revenir au sujet espagnol elle se sait
ce qu'ils se retroussent les manches
jose ayela la france du petit matin qui
construit contre la france du grand hall
appelant l'espagne en l'occurrence du
petit matin où l'europe du petit matin
qui construit contre celle du grand soir
qui détruit 1 par rapport à lagos et
c'est vrai que tout cela parle sans
doute à une bonne une bonne partie de
l'électorat lors vous disiez je rebondis
simplement ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous disiez c'est complètement
irresponsable d'avoir axé sa campagne
sur les libertés tout ouvrir en période
de qu'ovide mais en réalité on ne pourra
tirer le bilan de tout ça sans doute que
dans un an ou dans 18 mois peut-être
qu'on trouvera assez irresponsable au vu
du coût social parce qu'à un moment le
quoi qu'il en coûte on prendra quand
même dans la poche des français
est ce que cela aurait été irresponsable
d'avoir tout verrouiller de façon
disproportionnée parce que vous parliez
en effet des scènes auxquelles ont
assisté il ya un an en espagne
mais quand on lis tous finalement on se
rend compte que l'espagne la france
l'italie on pourrait dire les pays
latins qui ont plus ou moins qui ont
pris des décisions différentes par
exemple l'espagne et restaurants étaient
ouverts jusqu'à 17h et le couvre-feu
n'était que jusqu'à qu'à partir de 23h
et bien actuellement la crise sanitaire
est à peu près équivalente à la
situation française où là tout a été
verrouillé avec un véritable coup donc
la dame diaz auraient-elles tenu le même
discours si elle avait été premier
ministre en espagne pendant cette crise
sanitaire
absolument pas or et vert l'appel aurait
elle aurait décidé de laisser tout
ouvert de laisser les gens mourir elle a
eu ce discours pour gagner les élections
c'est le seul but de ce discours c'est
gagner les élections je peux dire
n'importe quoi du moment que je gagne
les élections
mais vous allez voir que si demain elle
en est là entre les mains le parlement
de la région de madrid
on va voir aux actes si vraiment elle
est comme ça aussi permissive que ça où
on va tout laisser faire tout ouvrir
accepter tout le monde on va faire
revenir tous les touristes sans aucun
contrôle sans vaccin sans pass
sanitaires on va voir on va avoir un
seul à l'espagne va être va être mis
devant cette réalité très bientôt
mais effectivement on va pouvoir faire
le bilan
si comme on peut l'espérer la pandémie
des croix des différentes politiques
possibles entre celle de la suède celle
de la france ou des petits bilan moi je
ne suis pas dogmatique parce que je ne
connais pas tout je pense néanmoins
qu'il faut rester extrêmement vigilante
en matière de liberté un jour je vous
rappelle que les chronos nos écoles nos
mairies liberté égalité fraternité là on
a l'impression que c'est plutôt simple
égalité fraternité c'est quand maman qui
est important donc chaque restriction de
liberté doit être pesé avec son coude
sur tous les plans et en effet il ya des
petits constat on l'a vu et ça ça comme
et un semi échec ou voir un échec total
pour le gouvernement traite la suisse à
a dit écoutez nous on a décidé de pas
fermer les stations de ski et finalement
de la situation sanitaire est plutôt
meilleur de notre côté du vôtre
donc voyez c'est ce bilan là un moment
où le tirera et il faudra bien quand
même faire le compte des destructions de
liberté du coup et de tous là où je
pense que pour le moment c'est difficile
de faire un procès à tous ceux qui
souhaitent un peu plus de liberté on
peut quand même constater une chose
c'est une grande différence entre la
france et l'espagne
c'est qu'aujourd'hui par exemple dans la
campagne des régionales il ya aucune
tête de liste nulle part qui ne fait
campagne sur le thème du coc vide c'est
quand même une énorme différence et je
pense que ça n'est pas un hasard
je pense que ça montre que à un moment
donné eh bien on peut pas on peut pas se
servir de tout pour gagner une élection
ne peut pas dire n'importe quoi pour
gagner une élection
et ça ça plutôt c'est pas tout à fait
vrai il ya quand même par louis appuyé
par marine le pen bon bah il la peine de
mort mais ses grandes opposants de
limagne almagro voilà donc cette visite
de la met de côté et elle
notamment avait insisté sur le fait
qu'elle trouvait une outrance et les
fermetures de lieux de culte un certain
nombre de restrictions de liberté je
vous donne les points de vue de nos
internautes ghiwane la droite triomphe
peut être de plus en plus partout en
europe mais ce sont encore et toujours
des décideurs non élus de bruxelles qui
continue à nous imposer leur virage
néolibéral antoine billot qui considère
qu'en france on a la droite la plus bête
du monde qui fait tout pour perdre
et puis c'est un pervis reims qui fait
cette distinction entre une droite
responsable à une droite trump heist qui
s'allie avec vox et l'extrême droite
si j ce pas déjà on revient à 7 cette
étude de ceux du cevipof dont je vous
signalais tout à l'heure que nous
n'avons pas pu prendre l'intégralité des
résultats mais voulait trouver sur le
site de cet organisme sur le site
internet c'est en accès libre
on s'aperçoit que il n'ya pas qu'en
espagne que la collabore donc ça
corresponde mouvement de fond pourquoi
et que la gauche qui est votre camp et
est aujourd'hui dix points derrière la
droite parce qu'elle est incapable de
pro 2 d'avancé un véritable projet
alternatif
parce que il ya un vent mauvais qui
souffle aujourd'hui sur l'europe et sur
le monde c'est le vent de trump qui n'a
jamais fait autant de voix aux états
unis même s'il a été battu
c'est le vent dobbels hoarau c'est le
vent de madame diaz en espagne un vent
mauvais qui souffle aujourd'hui les
grands mauvaise et contre l'immigration
oui c'est un vent qui en gros
aujourd'hui vient au pouvoir sur des
bases extrêmement malsaine sur des bases
d'opposition gones oppose les uns aux
autres on essaye on essaye de faire
voilà deux de construire une politique
uniquement sur le rejet d'un certain
nombre de gens alors on va rejeter les
on va rejeter les migrants on va on va
rejeter les gens qui nous empêche de
vivre qui parce qu'ils sont parce qu'ils
ont le coc vide on va rejeter ceux ci
cela donc c'est évidemment ça c'est pas
un projet de société c'est un projet
uniquement qui consiste à dire voilà on
ne veut pas de sens et de la gauche
et pourquoi est-ce que se vend
aujourd'hui les portes et pourquoi
est-ce que de plus en plus de gens se
disent se reconnaissent dans ce qu'il ce
que la droite peut incarner pire encore
l'extrême droite et bien c'est parce que
de l'autre côté il n'ya rien parce que
de l'autre côté il y a des forces de
gauche totalement désunis
qui n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord
sur une vision de la de la société sur
une vision de l'avenir sur un destin
commun sur une sur une identification à
ce que la france et l'europe peuvent
incarner de généreux de de positif mais
il y a un déficit de valeur il ya un
déficit d'identité un déficit de projet
et tout ça est bien un moment donné on
le paye
mais la gauche aussi elle a joué sur ses
ressorts là le parti communiste que vous
connaissez bien il prônait la lutte des
classes au long disait mon ennemi c'est
la finance c'est toujours comme ça en
politique non il faut il faut s'opposer
oui gagner sauf que hollande il a pris
la il a dit mon nom mon ennemi c'est la
finance mais une fois une fois arrivé au
pouvoir il en a plutôt fait son allié et
il les a bien servis à travers plein de
bonnes mesures c'est à dire à quoi car
si vous voulez le problème c'est que ce
qui s'est passé en espagne depuis trois
ans c'est que podemos à incarner quelque
chose de formidable podemos a changé la
vie politique en espagne et a fait
passer avant un souffle nouveau sur la
vie politique même dans de nombreux pays
d'europe podemos a donné naissance à
plein de mouvements leader qui était le
fruit mais le problème c'est que pour
des mots c'est au pouvoir depuis trois
ans et à partir et le pouvoir abîme
quand tout d'un coup on ne on ne fait
pas ce que l'on a dit c'est à dire que
quand on arrive au pouvoir avec des
désengagements de changer énormément de
choses et que finalement on se rend
compte qu'il n'ya pas grand chose qui
change eh bien oui
cette désillusion elle nourrit lll
elle est le terreau sur lequel
s'enracine et bien toutes les idées
populistes extremis est passée un peu la
même chose en en grèce 1 derniers mois
sur ce sujet oui ou non ils ne sont que
si les
et dites de droite progresse c'est qu'en
fait la gauche a complètement perdu pied
avec la réalité est plus que les idées
de droite c'est en fait simplement le
bon sens si j'ose dire qui s'impose
c'est à dire que vous parliez des
migrants et de l'immigration évidemment
chacun sait que dans sa propre maison il
ne peut pas accueillir plus qu il il ne
peut que sur la question du terrorisme
on voit bien qu'il ya eu alors je parle
de la france mais également des autres
pays européens il ya eu un échec patent
quand on voit tout ce qui est tout on a
le sentiment que la france est devenue
une zad ouverte à tous vents et un
certain nombre de pays aussi où l'on
rentre sans contrôle c'est une perte
totale avec le bon sens élémentaire
évidemment aucun continent ne peut se
déverser dans un autre sens dégâts et et
on ne peut pas laisser ddt des
terroristes puisqu'elle a remis par le
terrorisme faire les exactions sont qu'
ils ont en y mettant un terme donc en
fait le pas l'on peut parler également
du féminisme les thèses féministes
féministes qui en soit moi je suis une
femme c'est une très belle chose de
féminisme est pour les femmes
on voit bien que actuellement il devient
il devient fou les salles les théories
walk en fin et tout cela en fait ce sont
les excès de lagos qui tout simplement
on qui taxe le bon sens de deux façons
et de réactionnaire est évidemment un
certain nombre de gens se retrouvent
dans ses thèses ça fait plein de thèmes
on pourra voir va pouvoir faire dix
ambitions avec avec ses produits mais
actuellement ce sont des sujets sur
lesquels on revient soit comme jeudi un
autre thème à vous proposer c'est pour
ça que je me permets de vous de vous
interrompre non sans avoir salué
babineau qui nous dit sur les réseaux
oui la gauche est inaudible mais mbaye
dunn est perçu comme un centriste
je crois que c'est pas non plus un
extrémiste puis à antoine billot qui
interpelle j smadja podemos a changé la
vie politique alors j'ai loupé quelque
chose mais on refera le débat sur peau
des bosses et une autre fois on revient
en france vous le voulez bien je me
souvenais souvent de vous vous souvenez
sans doute pardon de cette interview
donnée par le président de la république
au figaro il ya deux semaines en disant
non il n'y aura pas de légalisation du
cannabis et pourtant le sujet
toujours d'actualité puisqu'il ya eu un
rapport parlementaire sur ce sujet qui
prônent une légalisation régulé du
cannabis qu'on appelle récréatif on a
mis ça entre guillemets parce que déjà
le choix de ce mot vous dire quelque
chose quelque chose de récréatif c'est
quelque chose d'anodin
mais c'est pour l'opposer au cannabis
thérapeutique qui est déjà utilisé dans
le traitement de certaines maladies
écoutez la coordinatrice de ce rapport
parlementaire qui est favorable à cette
légalisation encadrée
elle s'appelle caroline janvier lé
député en marche avec une légalisation
encadrée réguler on pourra mieux
protéger les français on pourra mieux
lutter contre les risques les risques
sanitaires d'abord de la consommation du
cannabis mais aussi lutter contre
l'insécurité et la criminalité qui sont
aujourd'hui associé à ces trafics et qui
gangrènent un certain nombre de
quartiers de territoires en france mais
je vous entendait réagir s'il est ce pas
déjà en écoutant 40 janvier vous disiez
quelle naïveté mais oui parce que parce
que le crime organisé qui vit qui vit
des trafics de drogue et notamment des
trafics de cannabis
on pense qu'il va comme ça à accepter du
jour au lendemain que bah oui on arrête
puisque le gouvernement décide où le
parlement décide de légaliser de ben
voilà donc on va arrêter ben voilà enfin
c'est du naïf face à n en pas ça mais ça
n'existe pas ça le le crime organisé va
se rabattre sur autre chose il va il va
inventer de nouveaux trafics
il va mettre des marchés parallèles du
cannabis avec des produits différents il
va il va quand on a quand on a levé la
prohibition sur l'alcool aux états unis
en 1933
est-ce que ça a mis fin au crime
organisé qui ceux qui vivaient sur
l'alcool du land
absolument pas du coup vous êtes contre
la légalisation et oui bien sûr je veux
bien sûr je sais pas parce que comme
dans cette émission ne manquent pas
avant mais je me sens ici je serais
content je ne vous dis pas que
alors je suis totalement conscient
d'être à contre-courant de ce que
pensent beaucoup de mes amis de ce que
pense une bonne partie de ma famille de
pensée et de valeurs de conviction
c'est vraiment conviction personnelle
oui je suis contre la légalisation
parce que d'une part sur le plan on a
des certitudes
au moins aujourd'hui c'est con sic sur
le plan médical la consommation
régulière de cannabis à des effets quand
même extrêmement désastreux on sait que
sa porte
il ya des tas de rapports d'études qui
ont été faites là dessus on sait que ça
altère la capacité de jugement
on sait que ça développe les syndromes
d'anxiété les dépressions on sait que on
sait que ça a des conséquences négatives
en termes de santé mentale de santé
voilà donc ça aggrave certaines maladies
respiratoires fin bref on a plein
d'éléments qui laissent penser que la
consommation régulière de cannabis est
très mauvaise pour la santé
voilà et donc on va légaliser quelque
chose dont on sait que c'est mauvais
pour la santé
ça ça me paraît totalement c'est ce que
vous des titres intéressants comme
toujours mais en plus sachant qu'ils
vous êtes c'est à dire que vous êtes un
des principaux dirigeants est le
principal collaborateur du maire de
nanterre à nanterre ya sûrement du
trafic de drogue comme y en a 2 2 dans
les normes et comme dans toutes les
banlieues et beaucoup d'élus locaux
disent il faut légaliser parce que ça va
me sortir de ce problème là bas tant que
ça ne croyez pas ça oui pas tant que ça
parce que les parce que les élus qui
connaissent bien le terrain qu'ils
connaissent qu'ils savent comment ça se
passe ne ne croyez pas ça un certain
nombre d'eux et d'élus voire même j'en
connais avec qui j'ai discuté
ils redoutent éventuellement une
légalisation parce que ils se disent que
demain le trafic peut se déporter sur
des produits différents plus dangereux
plus convoité qui peuvent nourrir
d'autres d'autres rivalité
les armes des drogues plus dures enfin
voyez donc attention je crois que non il
ne faut pas il faut pas penser que tout
le monde serait non je crois que quand
on connaît un peu cette réalité je pense
franchement on a un regard un peu plus
complexe sur sur cette réalité
gabriel uzel pas plus qu'à j ce matin
vous a demandé avant l'émission ce que
vous pensez en moi c'est un peu plus
attendu je suis désolé ce rythme la
surprenante mais en effet je partage
votre avis je pense que c'est une
aberration parce qu'alors on nous parle
du cannabis thérapeutique du cannabis
récréatif en effet vous avez raison de
souligner c'est encore ce vocabulaire
lénifiant chaque fois qu'on fait une
réforme dite produisant parle de
confiance aux bailleurs aussi ouais là
on la compagne de ses éléments de
langage propre à atteindre la méfiance
mais on parle pas du cannabis meurtrier
parce que je suis quand même étonné qu
est alors que nous nous nous ce nous
sortons à peine de cette polémique
terrible autour du jugement rendu
après le meurtre de sarah halimi alors
certes verdict surréaliste mais qui a
néanmoins reconnu que c'était sous
l'emprise du cannabis que le meurtrier
avait eu une bouffée délirante vous
permet d'aller beaucoup la parole à une
seconde et je vous la repasse juste
après c'est promis pour dire qu'il ya un
responsable politique qui pense comme
vous c'est gérard larcher croyez qu'il
et récréatif le le cannabis qui a
utilisé monsieur traoré pour assassiner
madame halimi vous croyez qu'il et
récréatif le cannabis est celui qui
conduit et qui provoque un très grave
accident sur la route qui conduit sous
l'emprise non je suis défavorable à la
dépénalisation oui voilà donc en effet
je partage tout à fait l'avis de gérard
larcher c'est c'est évidemment une
question de bon sens alors il ya tout un
tas de commentaires de raisonnement
spéciaux qui viennent alimenter le lol
ce qui l'engagent de ceux qui veulent
légaliser alors notamment nous dit ah
oui voilà c'est un trafic ça enrichit
les trafiquants des banlieues donc à
partir du moment où où l'état selon
laura légaliser c'est lui qui gérera
tout ça et ça coupera l'herbe sous les
pieds des trafics rend si vous avez
entièrement raison c'est faux parce
qu'évidemment ils trouveront autre chose
à ce moment là et les on voit
actuellement les dégâts du crack dans le
20e il ya d'autres drogues et qui
potentiellement peuvent faire l'objet de
trafics et de toute façon les
spécialistes le disent
même si l'état fournisse et du cannabis
on trouverait toujours qu'il est pas
d'oser de la même façon qu'il n'est pas
il n'a pas les mêmes qualités et c'est
d'autant que indirectement le fait de
conserver ce trafic de drogue comme
délictueux et bien cela permet aussi de
force aux forces de l'ordre d'aller dans
un certain nombre de territoires perdus
de la république pour ce motif là on
imagine si tout le monde ce serait des
quartiers où finalement chacun va créer
à ces petites occupations sans que l'on
puisse aussi sur ce motif et on sait à
quel point tout est imbriqué à un
terrorisme drogue délinquance sans que
l'on puisse pour ce motif la halle et
sur sur ces territoires là et puis vous
avez raison je crois qu'il faut que nous
pensions à nos enfants moi à ma un
psychiatre me disent on a jamais vu
autant de schizophrènes actuellement
chez les jeunes et dans les services il
me dit que c'est vraiment le l'angle
mort du reste des services de
psychiatrie on n'en parle pas beaucoup
et pourtant il y en a énormément il dit
il ya des gens qui peuvent prendre du
cannabis une fois deux fois dix fois
vingt fois ça ne leur fait rien il ya
des jeunes pour lesquels une simple
prise suffit à déclencher une crise donc
sans parler évidemment sur le plan
scolaire de tous de tous les
inconvénients que ça peut ça peut
représenter donc ce serait délétère de
laisser faire ça moi je suis toujours
surprise de voir ces dossiers avancent
et en suis en période de crise sanitaire
aiguë ou encore une fois nous n'avons
pas toutes nos capacités pour prendre de
telles décisions il ya consensus sur ce
plateau mais pas forcément chez nos
internautes merci à tous de réagir
d'être aussi nombreux à le faire au
cours de cette émission vous réagissez
en direct sur lefigaro.fr mais aussi sur
youtube et sur notre fil twitter hashtag
point de vue on vous pose la question
sur twitter justement croyez-vous au
cannabis récréatif
c'est à dire au cannabis commun un
produit comme un autre entre guillemets
vous répondez non à 59%
mais il ya débat d'abord parce qu'il ya
40 % de gens qui sont pas d'accord par
exemple prix one qui nous dit le
cannabis récréatif est tout aussi
respectable que l'alcool récréatif
s'il est consommé avec modération par
des adultes conscients des risques
qu'ils prennent
babineau qui rappelle que le sujet est
complexe fait que la france est
championne du monde de la consommation
de cannabis qui est terrible alors que
au contraire chardon bleu rappelle comme
vous le faisiez à l'instant gabriel que
le cannabis est un danger pour les
jeunes dans le cerveau n'est pas
totalement formés que des jeunes ont
perdu leurs études leur vie future à
cause de ce cannabis
et puis saint père virage qui nous dit
le cannabis c'est mauvais pour les
personnes mais les lois sèche ne
réduisent pas la consommation mais
augmente les trafics et criminalise
quant à nicole 06 elle estime que même
légaliser ça ne changerait rien les
cigarettes sont en vente libre mais il
ya quand même du trafic
justement les cigarettes j smadja ceux
qui sont favorables à la légalisation 10
mai les cigarettes aussi c'est mauvais
pour la santé l'alcool aussi et pourtant
cet emprunt est libre nourrit d'accord
sauf que sauf que on les études qui
existe dans ce domaine nous disent qu'en
gros il y à des paliers c'est à dire que
si vous buvez un verre de vin par jour
vous n'êtes pas un iphone alcoolique
si vous si vous fumez trois ou quatre
cigarettes par jour bon vous il ya peu
de chance quand même que vous développez
des maladies liées au tabac donc là
alors que le cannabis il est démontré
que la consommation de cannabis à quel
que soit le stade quel que soit le stade
elle et elle est nocive
elle a des effets elle a des effets
négatifs et puis en plus sur le sur
l'alcool et le tabac moi ce qui m'embête
si vous voulez dans le débat actuel
c'est que j'ai l'impression qu'on a
totalement abandonné l'idée même qu'on
pourrait peut-être dissuadé un certain
nombre de jeunes en particulier de
devenir des consommateurs de cannabis
peut être qu'on pourrait essayer aussi
de jouer cette carte-là celle de la
prévention
celle de l'information celle de l'
alerte on le fait pour l'alcool et le
tabac on le fait beaucoup pour le tabac
on le fait un peu moins pour l'alcool
mais on le fait pour le cannabis est ce
que vous avez vu une seule campagne
d'information quelque part pour dire aux
gens de ne consommer pas de cannabis
parce que ça telle et telle et telle
conséquence sur sur la santé sur la
santé mentale sur voyait donc ses ondes
les impressions que le ce ce set ce
socle de la santé qui est la prévention
j'ai l'impression que dans sur ce volet
on l'a complètement abandonné ses
cendres pour ça que
le président de la république dans
l'interview à laquelle je faisais les jo
dans le figaro apprenez l'ouverture d'un
grand débat mais pas sur la légalisation
éventuelle mais sur les les risques de
cette consommation merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis et point de vue revient
demain à la même heure et au même
endroit
bonsoir
[Musique]